as we've already seen the end of
fighting in world war 1 or I guess we
have the end of fighting in World War
one at the end of 1918 and so in 1919
it's time to talk about the terms for
peace and this happens at the Paris
Peace Conference and at this conference
you have all the parties of all the
major warring parties but the terms of
peace are dictated by the winners and
the major powers among the winners are
led by these gentlemen right over here
this is Prime Minister Lloyd George of
the UK Vittorio Orlando of Italy Georges
Clemenceau of France President Woodrow
Wilson of the United States and they
come to the Paris Peace Conference with
very different outlooks of what the
peace should look like we already
learned about President Wilson's
fourteen points it was very idealistic
it talked about making the world safe
for democracy
how people should determine their own
fate how we should have the
self-determination the end of Empires
free trade creating a League of Nations
so that you can avoid things like World
War one again the European side was not
quite as idealistic especially the
French as you can imagine the French the
u.s. lost a lot of soldiers in World War
one but the French lost a significant
fraction of their adult males in World
War one the ugly Western Front was
fought in their country so they were
much more eager to make Germany pay for
what for what it's done and so the terms
of the treaty with Germany the Treaty of
Versailles and the Treaty of Versailles
it's important to note is only one of
several treaties that came out of the
Paris Peace Conference it tends to get
the most attention because it was a
treaty with Germany Treaty of Versailles
and many people blame it for being part
of the cause for world war ii it so
humiliated Germany that it was so
unacceptable that it allowed a character
like Hitler to come along and and lead
Germany back into war but the Treaty of
Versailles was the Trudie with German
you have other treaties with the
Austrians and then and now since the
austro-hungarian Empire has been broken
up the Hungarians the Ottomans so on and
so forth but the Treaty of Versailles
did several things first and this was
kind of in line with especially the
French thinking is it assigned the guilt
to Germany so war guilt war guilt
war guilt for Germany and depending on
where you view you could view this as a
fairly strong thing the argument for
saying Germany is responsible for the
war is in in in late July early August
of of 1914 it didn't take much for
Germany to declare war on Russia than on
France and then invade Belgium I mean
this is literally a matter of days was
pretty clear that Germany was already
mobilized to do this it was eager to do
this and it did do this without much of
a much provocation at that point it was
really just based on Russian
mobilization now those who would argue
that this was a little strong would say
hey look look Germany definitely played
a role in the war and maybe escalating
the war but it didn't start the war you
have the assassination of the Archduke
of Archduke Franz Ferdinand of Austria
Hungary and it was supported by or by
elements in Serbia then you have the
austro-hungarians who put out these very
hard these very hard terms to the
Serbians bring these people to justice
immediately otherwise we're declaring
war it seemed like they wanted to
declare war they do declare war in July
of 1914 then the Russians they don't let
that just be a little regional conflict
the Russians decide to start mobilizing
given giving the German the Germans kind
of the the pretext to justify their
invasions to kind of trigger this blank
check that they've given the
austro-hungarian so there's a lot of
blame that could go around but the
Treaty of Versailles places it with
Germany and then this justifies the
rationale to make Germany pay for the
war so this leads to reparations
reparations for Germany which
essentially is like look Germany you
don't have to pay the Allied powers for
all of their lost especially their
losses to their economy due to the fact
that you you are guilty of of starting
of this war guilt and the reparations
were not just in paper currency the
reparations were in gold and resources
and so it was a very it was a very
tangible reparations now it's an
interesting question because these
reparations are often referred to when
people talk to these were disabling
reparations they brought the German
economy down and and it is an open
question they were large in mod
earn dollars the estimates I've seen is
that they were approximately four
hundred four hundred billion dollars in
2013 money now that is a very very large
number but it's not a huge number for a
reasonably sized economy like Germany
although the economy was in bad shape at
the end of World War one but it wasn't
it was this by itself it's not clear
whether it by itself would have
debilitated their economy more likely or
if you if you were to think this is a
cause it's more of the humiliation of it
that the generations of Germans many of
them 10 20 30 years in the future had
nothing to do with World War one would
be continuing to pay reparations to the
Allies so there's a question of its
impact on the economy and there's just a
faction the the question of how how
humiliating how humiliating it was and
as we go and only the reparations only
lasts for about ten years and a Germany
pays the equivalent of about sixty
billion dollars in modern terms sixty
billion in 2013 dollars that's
equivalent about five billion dollars in
kind of nineteen twenty money but on top
of the reparations the Allies were not
interested in fighting another war with
Germany although ironically by having
very harsh terms of the treaty they
might have triggered the next war in
World War two the rise of Hitler and
since they didn't want to have another
war with Germany they essentially
limited the German army to a hundred
thousand men which is a very small army
as we've seen in many of the the battles
you had battles with four or five
hundred thousand men so this is pretty
much this is pretty much almost just
like a like a police force it's it's not
really an army and they weren't allowed
any longer to have submarines u-boats
kind of any kind of heavy military
equipment artillery heavy artillery of
military airplanes battleships of any
kind so it's really just a scaffold of
an army so that they so that you so that
there wouldn't be another or they hope
there would not be another German
invasion and then on top of that Germany
was stripped of territory territory and
some of that was directly in Germany a
Poland was carved out Poland was carved
out out of part of part of the German
Empire so this is the new Poland that's
carved
out of the Paris Peace Conference so you
see right over here it kind of cuts
Germany into two pieces
East Prussia is still part of Germany
but it's all by itself right out here so
poor Poland is cut out Germany loses
Alsace and Lorraine which had captured
in 1871 after the franco-prussian war
mineral-rich reason region the French
have been eager to get it back
the Germans actually that was one of the
arguable justification why they wanted
to preemptively attack France because
they knew that France was eager to
capture it back at some point in the
future but on top of that Germany lost
its colonies and Germany was not as and
nowhere near as big of an empire say the
British or even the French it was
actually a fairly new country formed in
in the 1871 but it did have an empire it
had colonies in South West Africa just a
darker color southwest actually
throughout Africa throughout Africa it
had colonies in the Pacific it even had
a colony it even had a colony in China
and all of that was then given over to
given over to the Allies so the big idea
from the Treaty of Versailles that it
was most historians would say it was it
was really kind of sticking it to the
Germans the Germans felt it was
humiliating and one could argue that it
did help lead to some of the extremism
that we'll see in the next few decades
of Germany now the one wind that Woodrow
Wilson was able to get out of the Treaty
of Versailles is it did set up the
League of Nations the League League of
Nations now the irony here is that the
u.s. does not ratify the Treaty of
Versailles because it's suspicious of
these kind of extra national
organizations it actually wasn't happy
with some of the territorial
distribution that it was just giving it
from one empire to another as opposed to
kind of having self-determination so the
US was not actually a signatory it did
not actually sign the tree it did not
ratify the Treaty of Versailles but
regardless of that the Treaty of
Versailles had a huge impact and kind of
sticking it to sticking it to the
Germans now on top of that the Paris
Peace Conference as we've already said
had various treaties with the other
central powers and some of the and I'm
not going to go into detail on what
happened especially the Ottoman Empire
that's I think worth another video but
the big the big effect on the
austro-hungarian
Fyers is essentially not an empire
anymore it was split up into various
countries Austria was set up as a
separate country and actually and
actually the Treaty of Versailles in the
Treaty of Versailles Germany is is is
forbidden from in any way merging with
Austria German a german-speaking country
you have Austria you have Hungary
becoming becoming a separate state you
have a new state of Czechoslovakia you
have you have a new state of Yugoslavia
some of your vassal your the the kind of
the trigger of over one the desire of
having this unified southern Slovak
state is now becoming a reality Bosnia
and you have Bosnian Serbia and Croatia
and Slovenia are taken out of out of the
austro-hungarian Empire so you have a
major redrawing of the map of Europe
these some of these new nations here in
Eastern Europe are out of the old
Russian Empire they were able to declare
their independence some of its short
lived before kind of becoming satellite
states for becoming part of the USSR but
they have the short-lived independence
as after the fall of the Russian Empire
so the map of Europe is dramatically
changed due to the Paris Peace
Conference the Treaty of Versailles the
fall of the Russian Empire and the other
treaties that were outcomes of outcomes
of World War one